i want you all to meet michael gardner
and his ten-year-old daughter eva
a few years ago michael began his
journey to become a seamster and he
thrifted old clothes to make new outfits
for ava as a way to bond with her and
inspire confidence oh michael you're
like literally the dad we all wish we
had
um michael taught ava had a sew when she
was just five years old and they've been
collaborating ever since you have to
watch this
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys michael here and ava today we
are at liberty ministries thrift store
hoping to pick up some really cool
unique fun pieces that we're going to
mix and match refashion and hopefully
come up with something really cool and
fun wishes look guys let's go
[Music]
we are so excited to create new looks
from the thrifted pieces that we found i
was lucky enough to find a pair of levi
jeans for myself and i found this really
amazing blanket i got a little
sentimental i'm thinking of my
grandmother and for me i have this cute
damn shirt which we will upcycle and put
new cool details into it and i have a
pink curtains which i will upcycle and
make a new skirt all right so we're
going to get started sewing these pieces
up and putting together a cool
daddy-daughter look for you guys i am so
proud of my dad he has all of these cool
and unique ideas we can't wait for you
guys to see what we created hope you
like it
[Applause]
i love them please welcome michael and
ava gardner
[Applause]
okay
you did an amazing job with that sweater
thank you
i mean you are really good at sewing
thank you
[Applause]
and ava
i'm so happy to meet you
oh my goodness i have to just tell you i
really admire you guys and
why did you start doing this what was
the idea and inspiration
so i always say god turned my pain into
power um i grew up without my father so
when i became a dad i wanted to make
sure that
you know she had all the things that i
longed for when i was a kid so
she only just became the tool that i
used to bond with her teach her about
love self-confidence
much of what i struggled with growing up
without my father
i mean she's literally my best friend
you know she's
how do you feel about having a dad who
says something like that i love my dad
and i really feel like he understands
how much i love him
so for him to say that makes me feel so
good
and you deserve that
but
how why sewing what gave you the idea
for sewing so what's interesting is my
grandmom actually sold for my mom and my
aunts when she was
raising them
my sister actually
grabbed my mom's sewing machine and
started sewing and i just
saw it and just was inspired and then
kind of watching david's like
personality
she's kind of sassy and
fun so i just felt like maybe she would
enjoy modeling so i grabbed the machine
went thrifting started making her
clothes and i just put the phone up to
her and she started posing and here we
are seven years later
and ava like what is this like for you
um
you've got this awesome dad
and he has this really fun idea that's
really unique and interesting
what did you think were you like i want
to be a model i want to make clothes too
like what's your side of the story
i really love modeling i feel like it's
a big part of
of me
and i never thought about doing it but
when my dad started making clothes for
me i just
started
to feel
confident and to feel loved and to feel
inspired to model
well
um we all uh love how connected you both
are and the amazing clothes that you
create together so
when drew crew member and founder of
harlem fashion row brandes daniel heard
your story she had a message for you
watch this she's amazing
hi michael and ava i love what you two
are doing so much and want to help you
continue to succeed
i want to personally mentor you both as
well as invite you to our next harlems
fashion rose fashion summit there you'll
be able to chat with fellow emerging
designers and hear from some of the
biggest names in fashion
i'd also love to promote you two on our
instagram page you are both so inspiring
and i cannot wait to work with you more
is amazing
wait until you get with her she wants to
mentor you and introduce you to people
thank you
well thank you michael and ava gardner
for
being who you are thank you
being the epitome of what good dad
program really wants to be
and i just really am happy to hang out
with you guys today thank you so much
[Music]